[Música]
la agitación en burkina faso continúa
cientos de personas se movilizaron en la
capital en contra de la presencia de
militares franceses en el país
esto sucede semanas después de que la
embajada del país galo fuese atacada la
diplomacia francesa está acusada de
ayudar al presidente de puesto
polenga
movilidad nos movilizamos para solicitar
la salida de la base militar francesa de
camboisín y luego de la embajada les
dimos una nota donde les damos 72 horas
para que responsabilicen y respeten
nuestros puntos de vista y abandonen el
territorio pasado ese tiempo exigiremos
su salida por la fuerza
los temores de occidente no están
vinculados a la salida de Francia sino a
un desembarco de grupos rusos tal como
sucedió en Mali una idea que está
fuertemente instalada en el seno de la
población
realmente nuestros hermanos y hermanas
están hartos no queremos más de Francia
queremos ir a Rusia eso es lo que quiere
la gente de burkina faso no creemos una
pelea con Francia no estamos contra el
pueblo francés
sin embargo el presidente militar
Ibrahim traoré renunció a pedir ayuda al
grupo Wagner tras su mala gestión en
Mali allí la seguridad contraataques
yihadistas fracasó y se registraron
violaciones a derechos de los enviados
de la ONU pese a esto la influencia de
Francia en el sael se debilita en Chad
el gobierno francés apoyó el
aplazamiento inconstitucional de
elecciones a principios 2021 mientras
que Mali abogaron por los sanciones tras
posponer los comicios antecedentes que
llevaron a los burkineses a describir de
la conveniencia de albergar tropas
francesas